d'habitude plutôt sensible à la variété
au rap c'est bien l'opéra l'arche de noé
de benjamin britten que ses enfants
apprennent avec motivation
ils font partie des 300 élèves saint
quentinois retenu cette année pour
participer au projet enfants en scène un
projet piloté depuis 2003 par
l'association pour la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines
en treize ans plus de 4000 élèves ont pu
bénéficier de ce programme pour nous
l'arche de noé n'est pas un sujet
religieux c'est un sujet historique
c'est un mythe fondateur de l'humanité
le déluge existe dans toutes les toutes
les religions dans toutes les cultures
être but est vraiment de réunir tout le
monde
un il ya beaucoup trop de séparation de
communautés si bien heureux la musique
classique d'un scientifique censé plus
doux c'est plus calme une heure par
semaine depuis début octobre
ces deux classes de l'école régionale de
la verrière s'initie à la musique
classique
ce projet culturel a pour but de faire
participer les enfants à un spectacle
musical de haut niveau artistique et à
des concerts d'initiation de secret d'un
orchestre
on leur explique leur instrument ça va
être la voix donc on explique un petit
peu commençons à voir comment la protège
comme on utilise donc ils découvrent
toutes les richesses de leur propre voix
des exercices de mise en col de mise en
voix de l'ex-site de relaxation et de
concentration et puis à part la musique
pas la joie de la musique les faire
grandir
au mois de juin les quarante deux
enfants de la verrière rejoindront sur
la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une centaine d'enfants des écoles de
trappes 45 écoliers élan courtois et 44
et la vie ni mon teint ils seront
accompagnés sur scène par de nombreux
artistes dont l' orchestre prométhée et
les solistes de la villedieu
deux représentations sont prévues devant
les parents les 18 et 19 juin prochains